uh tell us what's what's happening now
in this
hopefully waning uh days of the pandemic
to the food delivery industry
yeah it's a it's a it's a great place to
start so like looking at the overall
food industry across restaurants and
groceries has
constantly been kind of this food away
from home food at home kind of paradigm
so
in aggregate it's about 1.7 trillion
dollars in spending and what happened
during the pandemic was as restaurants
closed their doors
we saw about a 20 decrease
away from
from restaurants and a real big boost to
grocers
as people stocked up on groceries
but simultaneously within that
we had a massive growth in both online
e-commerce for for
restaurant delivery for takeout and
delivery and we also had a huge huge
boom to online grocery which i think is
probably the biggest amount of growth so
in
restaurant food delivery i believe we
went from about
um
don't quote me exactly on this but like
something like
it's like seven percent um food of total
food sales going towards delivery to to
somewhere now about 10 percent
it's mostly take out and then we when it
comes to online grocery went from like
two to three percent to ten percent wow
so that's the that's the major jump
that's where instacart really came in
and saved the day for a lot of groceries
and now here we are people are waking up
and saying
we need to do this ourselves we need
grocers need to become technology
companies which is a very big challenge
and and that's why now you're seeing a
lot of the the 10 to 15 minute
vertically integrated players eyeing
this this tam of delivery of of grocery
uh which is about 1.1 billion dollars um
250 billion dollars of which is going
towards your traditional fuel
convenience stores and then the rest the
other 850 billion is you know your
grocery um your grocery outlet so
um
we went from from three percent to ten
percent and in the next five years we're
expected to go from ten percent to
twenty percent wow um
so that's a steady
you know two percent growth every year
for the next five years
and um
yeah so based on what you're saying
there it feels like uh the grocery
stores and the convenience stores are
saying you know what partnering with
you know instacart
doordash
um
postmates ubereats
uh might be
fine but
you're saying you're saying some of them
are just gonna decide to do it for
themselves and go it alone and maybe
stop especially in the grocery space are
you saying that instacart
is going to see their delivery service
go down because vaughn's or whoever
safeway decides you know what this is
our core business if one out of five
customers is going to take our services
by delivery why are we even having
instacart in the building why are we
enabling their business why don't we
just be fully integrated which i believe
is what whole foods chose to do correct
oh yeah i mean they sold to amazon and
amazon is building a very compelling
omnichannel offering now across in-store
with whole foods as the high-end kind of
banner and amazon fresh is kind of the
middle market kind of kroger
uh banner um and then the online
component which is amazon fresh right
and
and then
the other grocers i don't think can even
compete because they need a player like
an amazon to come in
and completely revamp everything from
their purchasing all the way down to the
consumer experience and the logistics so
they've kind of cobbled together these
solutions and i believe that over the
long term
um you know the albertsons and krogers
of the world will just buy their
technology from the likes of ocado
instacart etc
um and use them as picks and shovels if
those companies cannot offer those picks
and troubles um but the the real
interesting thing is the the rise of the
vertically integrated grocer that's
going to try to attack these guys at the
um at their at their knees so you know
by offering faster delivery
obviously not the same 40 000 items of
products that you would find in a
traditional grocery store but a much
more curated set of grocery items um
and pantry items for this category of
instant needs which we can get into but
um so the strategy for these vertically
integrated ones are those like the
jokers and the getters and the corner
stores uh which was obviously bought by
uber this is this new category of
lower number skus but quicker delivery
time correct
vertically integrated yeah and and
that's kind of the key here it's that
you know a lot of the labor laws in this
country and abroad do not support you
know sustainable delivery at high
penetration volumes and you see this
with doordash is now betting heavier
more and more on dashmart which is their
vertically integrated solution
so they're not actually making margin
off the product and i think you're going
to see a lot more players enter the
space because um there's been proven
models abroad with the likes of
guitierre as you mentioned
or however you pronounce it getter
gettier and delivery hero that have you
know really built billion dollar
businesses through dark kitchens and
dark um supermarkets dmarts uh darks
dark stores um that have basically
transformed you know vacant retail on
main street or off of main street and
transformed it into kind of a last mile
infrastructure that house
um commonly or you know
commonly ordered items from local
bodagos or or random you know corner
stores
so what we're seeing is
there was this model where post mates
or instacart uh i think were the ones
who pioneered this would send a
postmates i don't know what they used to
call them but a postmate or i don't know
they would call them your postmates it
was like a person a personal shopper
basically uh or instacart would send a
personal chopper for you a shopper
to a store that already existed in the
world buy your stuff deliver it charge
you a markup
but if you're
you know joker or i guess this new uh
corner shop
the concept is
that uber's corner shop would inventory
the items themselves have the drivers
there it's one app it's not two
different parties involved in the
delivery it's just one party and it's a
lot more seamless if you have a return
if you have an issue and then it knocks
10 minutes off the average delivery time
or something
yeah i mean you go from a you know
a traditional
i guess instacart was offering one to
two hour delivery now they're offering
30-minute delivery they to kind of
compete against these guys guru you know
gets here kind of pioneered the
10-minute model you know we're splitting
hairs at some point it's like
you know really what this is about is a
land grab for you know for customers and
in certain markets and the way to do
that is to go plaster a bunch of
billboards and say you're gonna offer
free delivery in the fastest amount of
time gorillaz is doing in 10 minutes
joker's doing it 15 minutes there's one
that's even called 15 20 which in the
name implies 15 to 20 minutes um does it
really matter we can talk about that i
don't think it really does between 15
and 30 but um it is a land grab right
now
heads up the days of the 60 40 portfolio
might be over you know 60 stocks 40
bonds bank of america and goldman sachs
both agree
mounting pressures from inflation and
the fed's upcoming tapering deadline
might slow down the economy and could
cause trouble for stocks and bonds i
think we all know that so diversifying
is more important than ever
it's also important to look at
alternative assets uncorrelated to the
stock market like contemporary art
according to our friends at masterworks
many savvy investors you might know some
hold 10 to 30 percent of their net worth
and art and here's why well according to
masterworks research contemporary art
appreciated 14 annually between 1990 and
2020 it's a pretty good 30-year run if i
do say so now you can invest in blue
chip art without paying tens of millions
of dollars
masterworks makes investing in iconic
art like trading stocks online they
securitize a multi-million dollar
painting and then they sell shares to
investors i've done it is really easy
and they just raised 110 million dollar
series a with a valuation north of one
billion dollars congratulations on
becoming a unicorn and guess what twist
listeners get to skip the very long wait
list to get on masterworks if you want
to invest just go to masterworks dot io
twist to get priority access that's
masterworks dot io twist and make sure
you read the important disclosures at
masterworks dot io slash disclaimer